j'ouvre tout de suite notre second thème
il est consacré aux nouvelles menaces
venues d'Iran et son programme nucléaire
le 28 février dernier
laïeu à l'Agence internationale de
l'énergie atomique des Sley des taux de
particules d'uranium enrichi 18 fois
supérieur à la limite autorisée pourquoi
et s'inquiétant première réponse premier
élément avec Marion Delpech faut-il
craindre
iranienne la récente détection par
l'Agence internationale de l'énergie
atomique de particules d'uranium
enrichit à 84%, se rapprochant des 90 à
valeur militaire dans l'usine
souterraine de Fordo inquiète d'autant
plus depuis les désengagements
progressifs de Téhéran vis-à-vis de ses
obligations initiales par rapport à
l'accord nucléaire de 2015 dont se sont
retirés les États-Unis il y aura pas de
retour en arrière c'est tout le problème
c'est ce qui suscite les plus grandes
inquiétudes euh et ce qui fait que
effectivement il y a tous les les
paramètres d'un nouvel accord sont très
complexes à mettre en place d'abord
parce qu'il y a une forme d'obstruction
de la part de terrain au dernier moment
et ensuite parce que on est sur une
ligne de crête et que il y a de la pour
ce qui est d'Israël il y a c'est un
concevable d'accepter qu'effectivement
il est le passage de cette ligne rouge
présenté comme accidentel par le régime
iranien l'important augmentation des
stocks d'uranium enrichi soulève les
suspicions de la IEA l'agence onusienne
entend statué sur la question après
avoir obtenu des engagements de principe
de l'Iran pour relancer la surveillance
de ses activités c'était la première
fois que je pouvais avoir une
conversation sérieuse avec le président
iranien sur ces questions cela a une
énorme importance ce ne sont pas des
promesses nous avons certains accords
qui sont concrets et en même temps je
dois faire mon travail et je n'abandonne
jamais compte tenu du contexte ukrainien
et de la proximité de l'Iran avec la
Russie beaucoup se fonctionne ce statu
quo est-il tenable on voit bien que
Téhéran veut pas se fermer complètement
la porte justement elle veut pas être
ostracisé et c'est probablement ce qui
est à l'origine de la stratégie de T1
vis-à-vis de l'Arabie Saoudite puisque
il y a eu la finalisation d'un accord et
ça a été fait sous l'égide de la Chine
et là de la part de téhéans il y a une
stratégie effectivement habile pour
essayer justement de de renouer avec des
pays qui ne sont pas dans l'orbite dans
ce club des pays parisiens cette
éventuel relance des négociations sur
l'accord conclut en 2015 entre Téhéran
et les grandes puissances pour limiter
les activités nucléaires de l'Iran en
échange d'une levée des sanctions
internationales contre le pays
on vous explique tout sur le nucléaire
iranien avec Agnès Levallois bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes maître de recherche
à la Fondation pour la recherche
stratégique et vice-président de
l'Institut de Recherche et l'étude
Méditerranée Moyen-Orient clémentaire
bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi chercheur
associé à l'Institut installation
nationale d'études iranienne enseignants
à l'Université Paul Valéry de
Montpellier je cite cet ouvrage que vous
avez dirigé l'Iran et c'est rivaux aux
éditions passées composées
à l'Iris l'Institut des relations
internationales et stratégiques
spécialistes de l'Iran auteur de ce
livre l'Iran une puissance en mouvement
qui a lui publiée aux éditions Eyrolles
et Mathilde Siro évidemment il est resté
à mes côtés on va revoir les chiffres
que qui ont été donnés dans dans le
sujet de Marion c'est donc on est le 28
février et la IEA communique sur ces
particules d'uraniments riches 83,7% des
découvertes en Iran il faut un uranium
ici à 90% pour produire une bombe
j'avoue que je ne connaissais pas tout
ça je l'ai découvert en préparant
l'émission Agnès est-ce que ce taux je
sais pas une colle mais est-ce que c'est
la première fois qu'il est atteint en
Iran pourquoi est-ce qu'il faut
s'inquiéter de cette information donnée
par par là il faut s'inquiéter parce
qu'on approche effectivement des 90 %
qui permet de fabriquer une bombe
atomique donc c'est un chiffre de 87,3
qui évidemment inquiète on se demandant
si l'Iran est vraiment arrivé à ce stade
puisqu'il y a eu des éléments développés
par les Iraniens pour dire que c'était
pas ils avaient pas forcément atteint
cela mais que il y avait peut-être des
traces qui avaient conduit à dire que ce
chiffre était un chiffre mis en avant
par ailleurs ce qui est important je
pense quand même dans ce cadre et c'est
que l'aïea soit à nouveau venu à Téhéran
que la ioa que les Iraniens est accepté
à nouveau que des des inspections et
lieux et donc ça c'est un point positif
qui montre que les Iraniens me
semble-t-il en tous les cas sont
toujours dans cette logique de d'aller
assez loin mais de s'arrêter avant le
dernier moment et qui est un moyen aussi
de négocier et de montrer que il veulent
gérer le temps et que c'est eux qui
veulent gérer cette négociation sans se
faire toute imposer de l'extérieur donc
ils sont vraiment sur la corde raide à
chaque fois c'est à dire que ils font
très peur donc il y a une mobilisation
autour de ces chiffres que l'on voit qui
sont annoncés mais qui est un moyen
après pour l'Iran de dire bon de se
montrer quand même responsable en disant
mais on accepte à nouveau les aspections
donc de faire retomber la pression à
partir de ce moment-là donc 83,7 il y a
encore un peu de marge si je veux dire
avant les 90%
clémentaire de depuis quand l'Iran
d'ailleurs est-ce qu'il faut employer le
terme de relancer son programme
nucléaire est-ce qu'il était vraiment
arrêté où il a été arrêté entre 1979 et
le milieu des années 80 parce que
contrairement à ce qu'on pense le régime
actuel ne fait pas du nucléaire une
priorité depuis le début c'est un projet
qui date de la période par la vie donc
la période précédente c'est un projet
qui a été construit dès les années 1950
sous les gîtes des Américains donc après
plusieurs décennie d'efforts il n'est
pas surprenant que les capacités
techniques du pays soient avancées dans
ce domaine puisqu'il a bénéficié dans
les années 70 notamment du soutien des
Occidentaux qui ne voyaient pas du tout
à l'époque une menace nucléaire
iranienne évidemment voilà le nouveau
régime a décidé de dénoncer tous les
accords parce qu'il considérait que
c'était un acte d'impérialisme des
traités inégaux et ce n'est finalement
qu'au milieu des années 80 pendant la
guerre Iran Irak que le programme a été
relancé de manière clandestine donc
c'est pour ça qu'il y a un doute sur la
finalité à la fois le contexte de la
guerre et le fait que l'Iran était
victime à l'époque des armes chimiques
et donc aujourd'hui il y a une sorte de
chantage nucléaire finalement la
République islamique essaye de focaliser
l'attention sur les questions nucléaires
pour ne pas aborder les autres domaines
c'est-à-dire les manifestations en Iran
la politique régionale du pays les
programmes balistiques et de drone mais
il faut savoir qu'aujourd'hui la
dissuasion iranienne n'est pas nucléaire
il y a pas de système d'armes nucléaire
qui existe en Iran c'est une dissuasion
militaire conventionnelle et on le on
l'a vu en 2019 avec des tirs de drones
et de missiles sur les installations
pétrolières saoudiennes qui ont enlevé
en 17 minutes 5% de la production
mondiale de pétrole et on le voit
également dans le soutien à la Russie
avec les livraisons de drones et
peut-être demain de missiles qui
pourraient toucher l'Ukraine et on y
reviendra évidemment sur ce soutien à
militaire de l'Iran à la Russie il est
très important pour comprendre la
situation Thierry Coville si on continue
de faire un peu d'histoire quelle est la
part de responsabilité des États-Unis et
peut-être même de Donald Trump pour être
précis dans la situation actuelle je
pense qu'elle était énorme donc il faut
pour compléter ce qu'a dit clémence et
l'accord sur nucléaire est donc signé en
2015 entre l'Iran et les 5 plus sains
les 50 conseils de sécurité Nations
Unies et l'Allemagne là qui permet donc
on le dit il est assez simple c'est
l'Iran donne des garanties qui sont
problèmes nucléaire sera restauratrice
et notamment ce que vous disiez le taux
d'enrichissement d'uranium reste à 3,7%
c'est un niveau civil en échange d'une
levée des sanctions bilatérale et
multinationales et multilatérale pardon
et donc cet accord et ça il faut le
rappeler parce que quand on dit ça
souvent les gens disent oui mais vous
comment dire vous êtes pro et non non
mais c'est pas moi qui le dit il y a eu
je crois quand Donald Trump prend sa
décision en mai 2018 de sortir de
l'accord il y a 10 ou 11 rapports de
l'UEA qui était chargé de contrôler
c'est à cause de montrer qu'il y aura
respecté parfaitement de cet accord donc
tu prends la décision de sortir de
l'accord que les choses s'adresse
actuelle c'est vraiment les États-Unis
et doivent être les États-Unis Donald
Trump pour des raisons sans doute de
politique intérieure enfin c'est ça
dépasse mes compétences et donc mais
Donald Trump se rend pas compte qui met
en place une sorte de mécanique tous les
mois honnêtement pas besoin d'être un
grand expert de l'Iran je m'appelle dans
la conférence de presse quand il a
annoncé ça il y a journaliste qui lui
dit mais qu'est-ce qui se passe si
l'Iran justement une question assez
logique sors des limites de l'accord il
faut pas qu'il fasse ça bon alors je me
disais ok donc il y avait pas être
surpris donc et aussi il faut rappeler
aussi l'histoire quand même pendant un
an c'était les modérés à l'époque en
place en Iran il voulait rester dans
l'accord alors leur économie a commencé
à être détruite à cause du retour des
sanctions américaines et ils ont quand
même demandé aux Européens nous on veut
rester qu'est-ce que vous faites et ce
que vous êtes prêts à lutter contre les
sanctions américaines donc je pense
qu'il y a et l'Europe a manqué de
courage à ce moment-là c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire donc je pense qu'il y
a une double responsabilité il a
responsabilité première de Donald Trump
qui sort de l'accord et qui donne la
main libre au bout d'un moment l'Iran se
dit mec c'est quoi cet accord quoi donc
on en sort progressivement effectivement
depuis la nuit 2019 il le détricote et
aujourd'hui ils sont à donc près de 84 %
le taux d'enrichissement d'uranium et
l'Europe quand même il faut je pense il
faut le dire qui n'a qu'à dit qu'elle
était juridiquement pour l'accord mais
qui n'a rien fait vraiment pour que
l'Iran l'Iran reste dans cet accord
alors on va continuer de dérouler la
chronologie donc à la suite de la
communication de l'Agence internationale
de l'énergie que atomique évidemment il
y a une prise de position officielle de
la part de l'État iranien via le chef du
département de l'énergie atomique
s'appelle Mohamed s l'ami voilà ce qui
nous dit
c'est un échantillon prélevé à côté
d'une valve c'est une particule qu'on ne
peut même pas voir au microscope ce qui
compte c'est le produit qui est stocké
après la production les inspecteurs ont
regardé le niveau d'enrichissement du
matériel traité et on trouvait qu'il
n'était pas du tout supérieur à 60%.
alors vous avez dit que c'était pas une
priorité de rythme est-ce qu'on peut
croire à représentant de l'État iranien
sur un dossier aussi sensible alors
c'est pas une priorité de régime
jusqu'en 2005 donc jusqu'à
l'administration Armani ninja donc entre
2005 et 2013 on rentre dans une période
où le nucléaire devient un moyen de
relégitimation du régime et devient une
question de propagande très importante
avec une comparaison historique qui est
faite de manière totalement erronée mais
pour manipuler si vous voulez les
sentiments nationalistes de la
population avec la période mossader et
la nationalisation du pétrole donc il y
a une quête du nucléaire qui devient une
cause que la République islamique veut
nationale pour relégitimer le régime et
donc aujourd'hui le régime utilise cette
question nucléaire pour jouer dans la
cour des une puissance finalement pour
parler des gars égales avec les
États-Unis avec la France parce que le
régime est conscient qui a une sorte
d'obsession nucléaire occidentale et
donc ça permet comme je vous l'ai dit de
d'éviter de traiter des autres sujets
mais est-ce que je reposais la question
est-ce qu'on peut est-ce qu'on peut
croire voilà un officiel sur un sur un
dossier comme celui-là dans tous les cas
on est dans une guerre de l'information
ce que je vais vous dire c'est que le
fait que ça soit un élément central de
la propagande du régime répond de
manière indirecte à votre question je
vous dis qu'en fait tout simplement le
régime utilise le nucléaire pour se
positionner sur la scène international
avec une sorte de victimisation à
l'extérieur et une surenchère sur la
puissance du pays à l'intérieur donc un
double discours un discours à
destination de l'extérieur en disant non
aligné regardez les
occidentaux les pays qui détiennent des
armes nucléaires n'insistent pas sur la
question du désarmement parce que c'est
pas dans leur intérêt ils préfèrent
traiter de la question de la
prolifération nucléaire donc c'est un
jeu du régime sur la salat
internationale décision des pays
africains des pays asiatiques donc c'est
un discours qui peut avoir une certaine
portée sur la salatationale donc le
régime cette carte là dans un moment où
il est très déstabilisé à l'intérieur
affaibli contester et donc c'est un
moyen si vous voulez de réaffirmer une
politique étrangère qui peut permettre
au régime d'éviter les questions comme
celle de la contestation interne par
exemple
oui et puis norme diplomatique
c'est-à-dire pour avoir aussi une
influence auprès de pays comme le Mali
le Burkina Faso le Zimbabwe le Venezuela
Cuba aussi la Syrie ça fonctionne au
prix de pays qui ne peuvent pas
contribuer au développement économique
du pays donc en même temps ça a un effet
négatif parce que la population
iranienne ne se soucie pas de cette
question nucléaire c'est une question
qui centralise l'attention en Occident
mais à l'intérieur du pays il y a une
fatigue si vous voulez par rapport à la
propagande du régime et donc il y a une
même une décrédibilisation de cette
stratégie de focalisation sur nucléaire
au détriment du développement économique
du pays Agnès quel est la marge de
manœuvre d'un organisme comme l'aïa dans
un pays comme l'Iran c'est-à-dire que
quelle capacité d'enquête ont-ils
vraiment
des capacités d'enquêtes d'ailleurs on
l'a vu lorsque l'accord a été signé en
2015 ce que rappelait Thierry Coville
tout à l'heure c'est-à-dire que les
inspecteurs de l'IA venaient pouvaient
regarder il y a des caméras qui
fonctionnent alors il y a toujours une
petite marge évidemment qui permet de
s'en écarter mais le fait que laua soit
sur place puisse mener des enquêtes même
si on peut avoir quelques réserves sur
l'accès à l'ensemble des installations
puisqu'on sait qu'il y a certaines
installations qui sont quand même
souterraines cachées qui a des doutes
sur certains sites mais ça permet quand
même d'avoir une idée assez précise je
ne dirais pas à 100% parce que je pense
que ce serait très compliqué mais ça
permet quand même de savoir où on en est
et de pouvoir justement alerter quand il
faut alerter ou au contraire comme ça
avait été le cas après 2015 de montrer
que l'Iran était dans une dynamique à ce
moment-là positive dans le sens où le
pays respectait les engagements qui
avaient été pris et on s'est depuis
qu'effectivement l'Iran ne sait plus
sentie tenue par cet accord puisque le
principal signataire s'en est retiré et
à partir de là évidemment la porte a été
ouverte pour faire ce que l'Iran
souhaitait faire et qui vraiment je
crois dans le cas de ce nucléaire
iranien vraiment une arme entre les
mains de ce régime et qu'il utilise vaut
mieux effectivement des peurs que
suscitent cette question et là je le
sentiment que de ce point de vue là ce
régime joue entre guillemets évidemment
très bien avec cette carte et que nous
nos bien évidemment alors je continue de
dérouler à le calendrier on est cinq
jours je crois après avoir communiqué
les chiffres inquiétant le directeur
général de l'ailleurs on l'a vu
rapidement dans le dans le sujet de
Marion Delpech il se rend à Téhéran et
il en revient un peu rassuré on va
l'écouter je crois qu'une amélioration
une nette amélioration du moins en ce
qui concerne mon dialogue avec le
gouvernement iranien a été
enregistrés je pense que j'ai été
entendu et j'espère que nous verrons
bientôt des résultats nous verrons bien
au cours des derniers mois la
surveillance de l'enrichissement du
nucléaire iranien a été réduite
ce système de vérification était lié à
des caméras qui n'étaient pas en service
mécanisme nous avons donc trouvé un
accord pour que ces caméras et les
systèmes de surveillance soit de nouveau
opérationnelles
qu'on était en train de faire
c'est-à-dire que le régime iranien qui
m'ani le show et le froid dans un
dossier comme celui-là oui alors il faut
il faut bien effectivement c'est
toujours difficile de déterminer quelle
est la stratégie aussi un problème de
manque de transparence dans la politique
on peut quand même penser que ils sont
pas complètement sortis de l'accord moi
je veux dire moi mon avis beaucoup de
choses ça tourne autour de l'accord de
2015 ils en sont pas encore sortis
officiellement il est pas mort
officiellement et je pense que le
problème pour on va dire les Occidentaux
c'est qu'on sait pas trop est-ce qu'ils
utilisent alors je connais une
déclaration d'un ancien mise à faire
étrangère iranien il y a quelques temps
qui a dit on est tout à fait capable
fabriquer une bombe atomique donc c'est
exactement ce que disait c'est que à mon
avis ils envoient des signaux notamment
aux exigences aux Américains en
dépêchez-vous de revenir dans la corde
parce que regardez on continue on va
fabriquer une bombe atomique et les
83,7% pardon ça pourrait rentrer dans
vraiment je suis incapable de j'ai
écouté un expert là sur lui disait que
c'est par hasard donc ça peut faire avec
tous les guillemets mais ça peut être un
nouveau signe de dire regardez on
progresse et je pense que là
actuellement on évite dans l'accord
parce qu'on progresse exactement la
difficulté c'est qu'il y a aussi des
gens en Iran alors c'est pas une c'est
pas une majorité qui on évoque la
possibilité de sortir du TNP à force
d'être aussi prêt ce qu'on appelle du
seuil quoi d'avoir une aussi importante
de maîtrise technologique on peut aussi
se dire qu'il y a un moment ils ils en
Occident en excellent on pense qu'ils
veulent gagner du temps toute la
difficulté de déchiffrer mais pour
répondre à votre question je pense qu'il
y a une décision quand même après tout
ce qui s'est passé effectivement en Iran
les la répression la mauvaise image
d'Iran le sentiment économiquement ça
peut pas continuer comme ça ils ont
besoin d'un retour des États-Unis dans
l'accord ils sont en train de donner pas
mal de signaux que on est prêt à
négocier et là je pense que là c'est
très clair on savait que les États-Unis
ne pouvaient pas négocier pour revenir
tant que il y avait un problème avec les
yeux donc là il y a à nouveau un nouveau
signal qui est envoyé Agnès Levallois
peut-être d'un mot est-ce qu'il y a
parce que nous on a surtout moi le
béotien une image un peu monolithique du
régime iranien mais est-ce qu'il y a des
lignes de fracture des courants qui
s'opposent par exemple sur cette
question du nucléaire oui on sait qu'il
y a eu alors par le passé et encore
aujourd'hui des tensions au sein du
régime tout le monde n'est pas n'a pas
la même stratégie vis-à-vis de cette
question du nucléaire alors aujourd'hui
c'est très difficile de savoir
exactement comment ça se passe au sein
du régime puisque comme ça déjà été
rappelé le régime est confronté quand
même à une contestation importante et
donc une situation intérieure
extrêmement difficile avec un régime
incarné par le président actuel qui est
vraiment induire des dur et qui veut
absolument rien lâcher avec d'autres au
sein du régime qui se seraient d'accord
pour ouvrir un tout petit peu le jeu
pour même mettre en place éventuellement
quelques réformes pour calmer cette
contestation qui les met en difficulté
et donc on voit bien que sur cette
question aussi du nucléaire ces tensions
que l'on peut percevoir même si c'est un
régime quand même très opaque mais
sûrement Thierry et
Clément auront plus d'éléments sur les
rapports de force au sein du régime mais
c'est très compliqué mais on voit bien
quand tous les cas c'est une question
qui suicide des discussions en interne
particulièrement face à la contestation
et à la réaction du régime vis-à-vis de
cette contestation alors on reviendra
évidemment à la situation en Iran mais
là on dézoom un peu pour parler de du
Traité de Non proliférations nucléaires
grâce à Tam traduis qui est juste
derrière le rideau de sens public dans
les coulisses rebonsoir table bienvenue
à vous l'Iran on l'a dit comme de
nombreux autres pays à signer ce traité
il dit quoi ce traité bien c'est la
pierre angulaire de notre système de non
prolifération il fait cette année ses 55
ans il a été adopté par un très grand
nombre d'États 191 depuis 2020 et repose
sur trois piliers la non-prolifération
des armes nucléaires la plus mélange
diffusion de l'énergie nucléaire civile
et le désarmement nucléaire dans le
détail il distingue les cinq puissances
officielles de l'arme atomique les
États-Unis l'URSS puisque c'était sa
date de 1968 le Royaume-Uni la Chine et
la France qui avait déjà effectué un
essai nucléaire avant 1967 et qui
s'engage avec ce traité au désarmement
et à ne pas transférer d'harmonucléaires
à d'autres puissances et puis d'autre
part et bien vous avez les États non
dotés de l'harmonie claire tous les
autres pays signataires qui s'engagent à
renoncer à l'harmonie claire enfin et
bien toutes les parties s'engagent à
faciliter les échanges de technologie
nucléaires à des fins pacifiques ce
traité a-t-il été efficace et ce qu'il a
permis d'éviter la propagation de
l'armée n'a pas empêché certains pays
d'acquérir la bombe atomique l'Inde le
Pakistan Israël qui ne sont d'ailleurs
pas partis au Traité de Non
proliférations la Corée du Nord aussi
s'est retirée officiellement du Traité
de Non proliférations en 2003 et c'est
doté de l'arme nucléaire bref le monde
n'est pas plus sûr et d'ailleurs en août
dernier lors de la lors de l'ouverture
de la Conférence des pays signataires de
ce traité le secrétaire général de l'ONU
Antonio gusérès a lancé un avertissement
alarmant écouté
les nuages qui se sont dissipés après la
fin de la guerre froide s'amoncelle à
nouveau nous avons été
extraordinairement chanceux jusqu'à
présent mais la chance n'est pas une
stratégie ni un bouclier pour empêcher
les tensions géopolitiques de dégénérer
en conflit nucléaire aujourd'hui
l'humanité n'est qu'à un malentendu à
une erreur de jugement de
l'anéantissement nucléaire
dans son discours Antonio Guterres ça
fait référence aux affrontements en
Ukraine aux crises au Moyen-Orient ou
encore au conflit dans la péninsule
coréenne il a donné un chiffre aussi
près de 13000 armes nucléaires sont
détenus dans les arsenaux du monde
entier et il l'a dit il y a urgence à
adapter le traité au monde inquiétant
qui nous entoure est-ce qu'il y a des
décisions qui ont été prises lors de
cette conférence du mois d'août et bien
non la conférence est soldée par un
échec au bout de quatre semaines de
négociations la Russie a empêcher
l'adoption d'une déclaration commune
mais les cinq États dotés de l'arme
nucléaire dans leur ensemble ne sont pas
exemplaires écoutez Béatrice Finn
directrice exécutive de la campagne
internationale pour l'abolition des
armes nucléaires en ce moment bien sûr
nous constatons un immense des filles
avec l'invasion de l'Ukraine par la
Russie nous avons vu des menaces
directes d'utiliser des armes nucléaires
mais nous voyons aussi la Chine et la
Russie augmenter leurs arsenonucléaires
le Royaume-Uni renforçait son arsenal
nucléaire et les États-Unis et la France
contribuent à cette nouvelle la course à
l'armement nucléaire on voit bien que
nous allons dans la mauvaise direction
concernant les armes nucléaires notez
que cet échec n'était pas une première
c'est le deuxième échec consécutif de
cette conférence puisque la précédente
en 2015 n'avait pas plus abouti merci
beaucoup tam-trannie pour toutes ces
explications vous l'avez évoqué tout à
l'heure clémentaire le fait que l'Iran
finalement pas par ce par ce discours
cette façon d'utiliser le choix il fera
sur le dossier nucléaire il draine
d'autres pays derrière lui une
démonstration avec un témoignage une
réaction celle de Daniel Ortega le
président du Nicaragua il le recevait le
chef de la diplomatie iranienne écoutez
ce qu'il dit
par quelle autorité les puissances
occidentales veulent-elles interdire à
l'Iran
s'il le veut de fabriquer de construire
des bombes atomiques
par quelle autorité veulent-ils retirer
les bons atomiques à la République
populaire démocratique de Corée par
quelle autorité
pour les écraser pas la plaque
alors c'est quoi c'est un nouvel axe si
on va simplifier je vais simplifier dans
ma question et je m'en excuse entre les
régimes autoritaires d'un côté on peut y
placer Daniel Ortega je crois et les
démocraties occidentales de l'autre
c'est
aussi opposé et favorable désarmement
nucléaires et donc non c'est des il y a
les non alignés effectivement Cuba des
pays qui portent ce message le Venezuela
mais je pense que non le le jeu iranien
consiste surtout à évoquer le double
standard c'est à dire dans les
déclarations à cette conférence à
laquelle j'ai participé
le discours iranien est toujours de ne
jamais parler du nucléaire iranien et de
toujours parler du nucléaire israélien
même si ça a été précisé Israël n'est
pas parti au traité donc c'est à la fois
un jeu comme je vous l'ai dit de
victimisation à l'extérieur pour une
sorte de tiers mondialisme nucléaire en
fait pour séduire les pays non alignés
et un défi aux États occidentaux aux
grandes puissances mais le problème de
ce discours iranien
on va traiter des grandes puissances non
occidentales doté d'armes nucléaires
c'est à dire la Russie et la Chine et là
on voit la contradiction dans ce
discours iranien parce que la République
islamique ne critique jamais le fait que
la Russie ou la Chine est-ce qu'on
pourra appeler une sorte de real
politique islamiste en fait donc parce
que la République islamique est devenue
dépendante de ces grands pays donc la
Russie et la Chine aujourd'hui alors que
le Shah d'Iran lui était plutôt
dépendant des États-Unis donc on est
dans ce schéma finalement où il y a une
propagande qui est relayée là en
présence du ministre iranien mais c'est
vrai que il faut reconnaître comme la
souligné Thierry que le retrait de
l'accord par Donald Trump a provoqué un
débat en Iran c'est à dire qu'avant il
était interdit d'évoquer la possibilité
de construire des systèmes d'armes
nucléaires et aujourd'hui un débat
ouvert et la situation en Ukraine aussi
la guerre d'Ukraine a créé ce débat avec
des groupes maintenant qui à l'intérieur
des élites politiques iraniennes
défendent une approche
militarisée du nucléaire donc
ça veut pas dire qu'il y a un changement
de politique globale mais que désormais
le débat est possible et s'exprime dans
l'espace public on a eu un ancien
ministre des renseignements qui a évoqué
la possibilité de militariser le
problème nucléaire avant c'était
interdit en raison d'une fatwa de
l'ayatollah ramené même si c'est une
fatwa qui est réversible évidemment mais
ça crée un tabou et donc on évoquait
jamais cette question même sous Armani
Nate donc ça c'est nouveau sur le
Thierry Coville le je lisais en
préparant l'émission une déclaration de
l'ancien secrétaire d'État aux Affaires
européennes pierre Lelouch il dit cet
hiver 2023 restera comme le point de
départ d'une course planétaire au
réarmement nucléaire
à une sorte de course dans la région
donc
je pense quand même contrairement à un
certain je pense que aussi l'accord
n'est pas mort alors on a beaucoup
entendu ces derniers mois c'est à qui me
dirait que la Corée mort je pense qu'il
faut rester prudent et je pense que la
clé pour pour répondre du côté de l'Iran
c'est vraiment est-ce que cet accord de
2015 est-ce que les États-Unis vont
revenir de cet accord là on aura la
réponse
c'est que qui qui entre autres a
vraiment poussé Trump à sortir de cet
accord sur nucléaire ce sont les
pétroles archers du Golfe et en
particulier l'Arabie Saoudite qui a
signé un accord avec l'Iran il y a
quelque chose c'est pour ça que je
voulais en venir à ce point parce que
c'est intéressant c'est à dire que pour
l'Arabie Saoudite c'était vraiment un
danger
l'Iran représente un danger l'Arabie
Saoudite et se sent éminemment fragile
et fragilisé d'autant plus que l'Iran a
des armes comme des drones qui peuvent
atteindre ces installations pétrolières
avec toutes les conséquences que ça peut
avoir et donc l'Arabie voulait
absolument empêcher l'Iran d'acquérir
le nucléaire et donc à pousser Trump à
sortir cet accord alors que c'est
exactement l'inverse qu'il aurait fallu
faire puisqu'on s'aperçoit
qu'effectivement tant que l'Iran était
dans l'accord il y avait quand même
beaucoup plus de sécurité que sortie et
l'Arabie Saoudite et bien était en train
aussi d'analyser cette situation se
rendant compte que le fait que l'Iran
soit sorti de l'accord et bien
représente une menace encore plus grande
pour les Saoudiens puisqu'effectivement
l'Iran est en train d'approcher du seuil
et du coup que fait l'Arabie Saoudite et
bien l'Arabie Saoudite se rapproche de
l'Iran parce que pour l'Arabie Saoudite
il est inenvisageable que l'Iran et la
bombe ou atteignent ce seuil sans que
elle puisse ensuite la voir puisque
c'est une question aussi de rapport de
force géopolitique que ce sont les deux
puissances régionales qui s'affrontent
et que il est pas possible dans ce
contexte là qu'une des deux puissantes
l'Iran dispose cette arme au détriment
de l'Arabie Saoudite qui estime qu'elle
doit être la deuxième force à égalité
avec l'Iran dans le golfe est-ce que
l'alternance aux États-Unis l'arrivée au
pouvoir de Joe Biden
optimiste justement sur un retour de
l'accord nucléaire avec l'Iran enfin que
comment ça se passe mais on a bien vu
dès que Biden est arrivé au pouvoir il a
relancé les négociations avec son envoyé
spécial qui était en charge justement de
cette négociation avec l'idée pour Biden
avait le il avait la conviction qu'il
fallait absolument que les États-Unis
recignent un accord pour justement plus
de sécurité dans le golf ça c'était un
élément tout à fait déterminant après la
question qui se pose avec cet accord sur
nucléaire c'est un autre point qui
n'avait pas été abordé dans l'accord de
2015 qui est la question de l'influence
régionale et des missiles balistiques et
ça les pays du Golfe et les Européens
voulaient absolument inclure ces deux
sujets dans cet accord alors que les
Iraniens disaient écoutés nous on
revient dans la cortège qu'il a été
signé et on met ça de côté et là-dessus
il y a eu la guerre en Ukraine enfin
l'invasion russe de l'Ukraine et qui a
vraiment fait capoter cet accord que
tout le monde disait on était
pratiquement sur le point d'oxyde et
peut-être le principal soutien militaire
de de la Russie aujourd'hui et donc
forcément pour les États-Unis rediscuter
avec l'Iran ça semble ça semble
pratiquement compliqué bon je simplifie
mais c'est un peu l'idée je voudrais
vous entendre quand même clémentaire sur
ce qui a été signé entre l'Iran et
l'Arabie Saoudite je crois que c'était
vendredi dernier qu'est-ce que ça peut
surprendre effectivement qu'est-ce qui a
été signé c'est quoi cet accord c'est
pas une surprise ça fait plusieurs
années ça fait plus de 2 ans qu'il y a
des négociations donc il y avait cette
idée que comme l'expliquait Agnès
l'échec de la politique de pression
maximale a conduit si vous voulez à des
tirs de missiles et de drone et des
attaques sur des tankers dans le détroit
d'hormones il faut rappeler que 20% du
trafic mondial de pétrole circule dans
des normaux c'est 30% du trafic maritime
la Chine importe 40% de son pétrole du
Moyen-Orient donc en toute logique il y
a un intérêt à une désescalade militaire
depuis 2019 donc c'est une dynamique qui
précède si vous voulez l'administration
Biden alors l'administration Biden n'a
jamais pu vraiment
c'est quoi cet accord en fait entre eux
c'est simplement un accord de non
interférence dans les affaires internes
de de chaque État alors toute la
question va être de l'interprétation
est-ce qu'il s'agit de l'arrêt de
l'interférence de l'Iran au Yémen où
est-ce que ça inclut aussi l'Irak le
Liban la Syrie dans parce qu'il y a des
réseaux d'influence de l'Iran dans toute
la région donc c'est quand même un
accord qui est à tester si vous voulez
c'est un accord qui est qui doit être
mise en œuvre maintenant donc on a déjà
vu avec la course au nucléaire les
difficultés des compromis diplomatiques
et les interprétations divergentes donc
je dirais que actuellement si vous
voulez la politique américaine dans la
région a produit aussi cet accord sous
l'égide de la Chine en raison de la
continuité de la politique chinoise des
intérêts économiques qui faisaient
l'intermédiaire entre l'Iran un commerce
très significatif avec l'Arabie Saoudite
85 milliards de dollars 15 milliards
avec l'Iran donc c'est un peu comme la
politique des deux piliers de
l'administration Nixon dans les années
70 c'était le Shah d'Iran à l'époque
mais à l'époque c'était le Shah d'Iran
qui était le plus important aujourd'hui
c'est l'Arabie saoudite l'Iran est très
affaibli donc l'Arabie saoudite a choisi
de signer cet accord à un moment où
l'Iran est acculé l'Iran est en grande
difficulté interne et donc il y a cette
idée du risque d'une attaque à
l'extérieur comme en 2019 pour réprimer
à l'intérieur je voudrais continuer sur
cet accord avec vous Agnès Levallois
parce que c'est quand même un camouflé
pour Israël bien sûr parce que Israël
négociait essayer d'intégrer l'Arabie
saoudite à un accord présent on va
essayer d'être le plus simple possible
mais qu'est-ce que ça peut provoquer
comme réaction d'Israël tiens ça va
plutôt être ça Mac le plus simple
possible pour essayer de comprendre ça
c'est que Israël s'est lancé dans une
stratégie de normalisation avec des pays
de la région donc à signer des accords
avec les Émirats arabes unis avec
Marlène avec le Maroc et le Soudan et
voudrait entraîner l'Arabie Saoudite
pour l'instant c'est plus compliqué pour
l'Arabie Saoudite parce que d'abord le
roi le roi Salman n'a aucune envie et
considère quand même que la cause
palestinienne est une cause qu'il a
qu'il a défendu toute sa vie son fils
prince héritier est beaucoup moins la
tenue par cet accord mais pour l'instant
ne va pas des contre la volonté de son
père ce qui n'empêche qu'il y a des
relations quand même très très suivies
entre les saoudiens et les Israéliens
mais le Netanyahu donc le premier
israélien espérait vraiment obtenir de
l'Arabie la signature d'un accord avec
l'état d'Israël contre l'Iran évidemment
et donc le fait aujourd'hui que l'Arabie
signe cet accord avec l'Iran donc c'est
la reprise de relation diplomatique qui
avait été rompue il y a quelques années
evidemment ça met en difficulté la
position israélienne puisque cette idée
ou ce rêve de la part des Israéliens de
pouvoir avoir un front uni de toutes les
pétromanarchies du Golfe avec quand même
le la plus importante qui est l'Arabie
Saoudite pour l'instant est mis quand
même de côté à l'heure où on entend
quand même beaucoup de bruits de botte
côté israélien qui est les Israéliens
qui disent à travers leur centre de
recherche et un certain temps de
déclaration que il serait prêt alors
apprendre évidemment beaucoup de
précautions mais amener des opérations
contre des sites
iranien pour ne pas laisser justement
l'Iran aller à ce fameux seuil dont on a
parlé tout à l'heure donc on est dans
une configuration aujourd'hui dans la
région où Israël fait ses déclarations
l'Arabie Saoudite contre toute attente
même si le processus était lancé ce que
les premières négociations ont lieu à
Bagdad il y a 2 ans entre les Iraniens
et les Saoudiens donc on savait que ce
processus était en cours et que pour le
prince héritier c'était extrêmement
important de lancer cette négociation
parce que il est pas bête il a compris
que si vous voulez une certaine
stabilité dans le golf une certaine
sécurité ça passe par une négociation
avec l'Iran parce que les Américains ne
sont plus près à faire tout et n'importe
quoi pour les protéger et la France dans
tout ça on va terminer avec avec cette
question Mathilde je me tourne vers vous
nucléaire c'est un peu vous dites
l'éléphant dans la pièce entre Paris
était en pourquoi on a vu l'activisme
d'Emmanuel Macron sur ce mouvement qui
est à l'oeuvre en Iran sur la révolution
des iraniennes notamment contre le
régime des mots là Emmanuel Macron a été
le premier
les gens occidental à soutenir cette
révolte c'était en novembre il avait
reçu des militantes justement à l'Elysée
c'était donc un geste assez fort
symbolique au nom de l'universalisme de
la défense des libertés qui a suscité
beaucoup d'espoirs du côté du peuple
iranien qui a permis aussi de faire en
quelque sorte oublier la poignée de main
avec IC à l'ONU le président français
avait aussi appelé à une action forte de
la communauté internationale et depuis
cela il est quelque peu resté au milieu
du gué et certains soupçonnent même du
côté de Bruxelles notamment que la
France va fasse partie des pays qui
freinent le processus qui est lancé au
niveau de l'Union européenne d'intégrer
les Gardiens de la révolution donc cette
cette armée en quelque sorte de la
République islamique qui est impliquée
dans la répression de la population à la
liste européenne des entités terroristes
Paris en fait ne veut pas prendre le
risque de la rupture totale pour
l'instant avec le régime
de peur en fait d'une prolifération
nucléaire et de potentiel représailles
également qu'est-ce qu'on peut dire des
relations entre le régime iranien et la
France elles sont tendues
particulièrement tendues elles se sont
en fait plutôt dégradées ces derniers
mois on se souvient des drapeaux des
drapeaux français qui ont été brûlés
devant l'ambassade de France à Téhéran
c'était au début du mois de janvier les
menaces contre Charlie Hebdo à la suite
des caricatures pour ne pas s'en prendre
ouvertement aux États-Unis l'Iran semble
vouloir plutôt cibler la France on
rappelle d'ailleurs qu'il y a des
ressortissants français et qui sont
toujours en prisonnés par le par le
régime on reproche à la France d'avoir
en quelque sorte laisser tomber l'Iran
après le retrait américain de l'accord
sur le nucléaire pourtant Emmanuel
Macron a dénoncé récemment la fuite en
avant des Iraniens sur le nucléaire donc
on voit bien que cette relation et cette
rupture on s'y approche mais le risque
pour la France mais que la France pour
plus largement les Européens ce serait
d'isoler définitivement l'Iran puisque
cela revient à renforcer un axe qui se
constitue avec la Chine et la Russie
merci beaucoup je voudrais savoir
Thierry covid ce que pèse la France en
Iran la question elle bouge beaucoup
trop large mais est-ce que est-ce qu'il
y a une possibilité que voilà la France
joue un rôle je reste sur ce dossier du
nucléaire
aujourd'hui c'est à dire effectivement
donc depuis 2018 on peut dire c'est
vraiment comme Agnès a parlé des dures
des durs donc c'est les plus radicaux
des radicaux qui dirigent et c'est vrai
que eux ils ont tendance à croire qu'on
est qui est un camp occidental et autant
il y avait un certain prestige de la
France avant moi quand j'y étais
quelques années à la France un pays
indépendant des États-Unis pour les
dures en Iran et justement c'est ça le
drame aussi de l'accord ils ont ils ont
la preuve que on s'est rangé du côté
américain on n'a pas osé affronter les
Américains européennes etc et
malheureusement pour les dures il voit
pas la différence pour confirme ce que
vous venez de dire il voit pas du tout
la différence entre les Européens et les
Américains au mieux on est au service
des États-Unis ils ont même ils emploi
même des expressions beaucoup plus dures
par rapport à notre égard donc là
vraiment je pense qu'on a
on a loupé quelque chose mais est-ce que
effectivement c'est plus facile parce
que ce que disait Mathilde de d'attaquer
la France plutôt que d'attaquer
frontalement les États-Unis aussi non
pas forcément enfin
attaquer les États-Unis
alors je veux dire oui vous avez raison
effectivement à l'équipe non mais c'est
et il y a eu il y a quand même des en
série regarder ce qui s'est passé quand
euh sur les manies le général iranien
était assassiné début 2020 donc les deux
pays l'Iran les États-Unis c'est vrai je
vous reconnais ils veulent pas la guerre
direct avec les États-Unis mais il y a
des un affrontement indirect non non moi
je pense que la clé de nouveau je pense
qu'on a assez dit ce soir c'est on peut
pas tout régler avec l'Iran et je pense
que la clé je pense que c'est ça qui
rend prudent les les diplomaties
notamment françaises même en dépit de
tout les tensions c'est le les
négociations sont nucléaires tant qu'on
pourra pas dire que la corne n'existe
plus bon on peut pas tout régler avec
l'Iran et moi je pense que le début
soyons prudent du possible diminution
des tensions éclairantes ça passe par
cet accord donc les diplomaties
françaises regardent toujours cet accord
et essaie de pas trop brusquer l'Iran de
ce point de vue là bon allez-y la
question des otages est quand même une
question essentielle dans la relation
entre la France et l'Iran puisqu'on a
quand même plusieurs
otages et que ça ça gêne aussi et ça
bloque un peu la stratégie de la France
parce que comment négocier ou comment
trouver des ponts avec cette cette
pression qui est qui représentée par la
présence de 7 ou 8
otages dans les prisons iraniennes alors
le débat est quasiment terminé mais je
bon il est sur le nucléaire iranien mais
je voudrais quand même vous poser une
question sur le mouvement parce qu'on en
parle plus du tout il y a toujours des
manifestations dans certaines villes du
pays qu'est-ce qu'il en est où les
célébrations du Nouvel An iranien il y a
des manifestations qui ont eu lieu dans
tout le pays donc c'est pour ça que la
France ne peut pas en fait se focaliser
que sur le nucléaire iranien parce que
il y a un conflit idéologique
c'est évident entre une théocratie
obscurantiste et un pays comme la France
qui prétend défendre des valeurs donc je
pense que le président iranien c'est le
président français pardon s'est rendu
compte très rapidement après la
rencontre avec ici comme vous l'avez
souligné de la nécessité d'une
correction de cette politique seulement
focalisée sur le nucléaire et avec
l'implication iranienne
en Russie dans la guerre contre
l'Ukraine il est très peu probable que
la France puisse résister à la pression
allemande parce que c'est l'Allemagne
qui mène la politique européenne sur la
question iranienne d'aujourd'hui merci
beaucoup merci de nous être adapté à la
fin de l'émission désolé je vais
rappeler le le titre de vos livres alors
clémenter je commence avec vous l'Iran
et c'est rivaux c'est aux éditions
passées composées et Thierry covid
l'Iran une puissance en mouvement aux
éditions eyrol merci encore d'avoir
participé à ce débat qui était
passionnant je vous dis à lundi
évidemment puisqu'on est jeudi soir et
votre prochain rendez-vous politique sur
notre antenne l'invité de la original
Stéphane séjourné députés européens
secrétaire général de renaissance il
sera face à Oriane Mancini à 8h du matin
belle soirée